to welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
the number one place to come get upset
when you're trying to relax that is our
pledge to you many of you may have
noticed our last episode there was a lot
of criticism for it it's sitting
currently at 50% dislikes which is our
second most disliked video of all time
brutal very yeah brutal - I'm not gonna
lie I feel very stupid and humiliated
and bad for those that didn't notice or
look in the comments or anything people
were upset with how I was treating Ian
that I was bullying him and berating him
being mean to him yada yada not nice I
was not nice to eat and I went back and
watched the clip and I agree with you
guys I feel very humiliated I feel very
stupid that that you know I'm that I'm
upset everybody so much he said his mom
called him and was like what did your
mom say in well she just thought I was
like about to die from illness but you
know she feels a little uncomfortable
sometimes I suppose because the way she
perceives it not actually what's
happening but the way it comes across I
suppose on air so the fact that I've I
have upset Ian's mom Ethan Bradberry
would not be happy good point
I haven't been good tiens mother no so
yeah I feel really stupid I feel really
ashamed and just dump it I don't know
that the thing is like these three guys
back here I love them they're like my
family and I guess sometimes that
doesn't come across here but our
conversations like when I'm on when I'm
on the air I'm doing like I don't know
why I'm doing this shtick where it's
like maybe it goes back to like Ian the
intern thing which was a long time ago
he's in the cellar employee now but like
sometimes we do this shtick where it's
like I'm this crazy boss and I'm like
ordering them around but I mean
off-camera it's not like them know so I
think I think that because people only
only see into our world for that one two
hours that were together here in the
studio and they don't see that we're
hanging out before and after the show
that we're on what's up all the time
chatting when we talk like every day all
day on our what's up groups and we're
always so immersed in everything but
then the whole week doesn't translate
into the episode the episode is just
those two hours so but that being said I
mean I washed it back and I I definitely
was like I don't know why I the thing is
I love in and I want him to be a part of
the show so like I I think in my mind I
was like I just wanted to include him
but watching about I was like taking and
digging and digging and digging and just
going on for too long right but I want
but like I want I guess I do wonder
though because of the reaction like I
second get second guess because I I know
that I love you guys and I cherish you
guys and I respect you guys and I would
do anything to keep you guys happy and
you know I think you're so important
part of the show but I wonder if you
guys think that I am at time to make you
uncomfortable
you wait for response sorry yes I mean
uh no like you said it's I think a lot
of it is just how it comes across on the
air you know the point that you made
about just people only having this like
kind of short glimpse into what the
dynamic actually is between us you know
it kind of limits it limits the
perspective in a way and so you know I
want to say that like I do I do actually
understand why people perceived it that
way like when you when you take a step
back and watch it and try and put
yourself in the shoes of somebody that
doesn't have the context of like what
our working relationship is like you
know when we're not on camera yeah I
mean it did come across as as bullying
and employee and you know like you said
long-term Watchers of the show have
known that that's been a shtick for a
long time but I think in that particular
you know last episode like you said it
went on a little too long you know but
on the other hand too
you know I I do want to say that you
know from my perspective and it's it
ends the one that this is about so I'll
let you speak to that but you know it
was a little bit about you too don't
know about our conversation with you too
about the villainous I guess your
perspective is also you know relevant
yeah I mean I did see some of that too I
feel like that one is less a hard to
extract these things from each other
because I think that almost as a
separate conversation just because there
are a lot of people that just and myself
included felt like that conversation
went on way too long and you know wasn't
really productive and a lot of people
you know we even talked about it right
at the conclusion of the conversation
that a lot of people you know they don't
come here to hear about politics they
hear about it from everywhere else all
day and they come here to have a laugh
and when the conversation gets bogged
down in this debate for you know 35 40
minutes you know it's
annoying to people and so but but yeah I
mean at least based off of the reaction
on the subject it seemed like it was
much more about your dynamic with Ian
yeah and to that I mean you know we're
all we're all adults here like you know
I know people think that they want to
speak up and you know Ian can speak to
this but he's been getting messages from
a lot of hands like are you okay man and
it's just like you know you don't have
to do that you don't like we're okay
we're doing pretty good over here
actually so but I definitely am egga
fail yes right no yeah yeah I think I
think and I think it's big of you to
understand that and accept that that you
know not trying making excuses for it
like we we do appreciate that
it's not coming off well and you know so
we should probably knock it off I mean I
can tell when we're doing that kind of
stuff that our intention is to try to
create some kind of funny drama or you
know some goofing around drama between
us all cuz it's usually it's pretty fun
but I think in this case that some of
the lines get blurred of like what's
real what's a stick when yeah who's
kidding who is not kidding right I do
like I found that I find like the inner
office drama was like really compelling
and entertaining yes my favorite stuff
from the podcast so like I'm trying to
play it up but like an effort to draw it
out and it's something I just like was
beating the [ __ ] out of a dead maimed
horse but I I asked I mean I asked in
you know because like I said I was
second-guess myself as it Ian I mean
I'll ask you in do I I mean how did you
react to that segment when we were on
there um I mean afterwards it didn't
really feel like anything different from
normal it felt I didn't think twice
about it I was fine I didn't even really
revisit it in my mind at all I was like
okay another day of work maybe people
will just say I have Stockholm Syndrome
or so but then I was getting messages
and then seeing the subreddit and it
made
it seemed like like you just slapped me
on air and clap those cheeks or
something without the clap those cheeks
yeah right in the middle of the podcast
room and I actually watched it back and
then it felt even less of a big deal
than I remembered it being it didn't
seem that bad to me I do see how people
could perceive it that way though in the
way we do engage cuz like you know I was
goofing back it wasn't yeah it wasn't a
huge thing to me but you were asking
like personal questions and I could see
how people could be offended on my
behalf in case on the off chance I was
upset I wasn't but I could see how
people could think that way it makes
sense to me it makes sense to me too I
washed it back I was like I was telling
myself to just shut up and move on my
you know what I mean it's like so
frustrating to watch myself and be like
why do you keep going on and on about
this but like when I so the thing is
when we're in this office and I'm
looking at the monitor I see you guys
and in here people are I see like Dan
and Zach are smiling and laughing having
fun and when I see in when I wash back
the segment he was joking around and
having what I felt I thought looked like
fun - I just seemed like a douche who
wouldn't [ __ ] move on but it seemed
like I mean you were making the best of
it you were goofing a gaffe it and
having a laugh which is good I mean
that's the that's my hope from it but
obviously I look like a massive I mean I
I don't know I mean I'm just I am on one
other hand surprised at how far people
took it because I think III would think
that people who have been watching the
show long enough with no but maybe I
think maybe just that there was
something off about the tone where I
don't know what it was but maybe like
use Ian we were talking about this
before we went on the air and had
suggested that maybe it was the personal
nature of the questions I was asking him
to I just I personally I loved in I
think he's
Bonnie I think he's talented and I like
to include him in the show as much as I
can so I mean oh all three of you guys
we yeah you know but I guess it's not
obvious to people who are watching
because they don't see our normal
interactions so all they see is like the
yelling it in I mean am i a my shitty
boss is they everyone thinks I'm the
boss from hell and I don't know I also
think that maybe it's the framing you
create a framing that I am in a position
of like you are bullying me and then you
create that kind of structure around it
and then dig into it yeah like for
example I'm kind of sick I don't know I
maybe I have the flu or something but
then you created like are you depressed
are you not eating
are you like having a chronic illness
suddenly my mom thinks I have a chronic
illness and then everyone reading that
put me in a position of being like so
helpless I go and then dig into it and
then people feel even more empathetic to
me when really I just you know have a
have a cold or something but I think
that might be the contributing thing is
the way that you're framing it yeah it
didn't look good because you made a
comment about me um and I bought some
teddy fresh that you were kind of like
mentioning and it became this whole
thing even about that and about just
both of us being like I got a I got to
say something about that
because I saw people trashing ela she
didn't even say anything all right
like I was ringing with you and stuff
like that so even that alone people were
like why is he lying okay would it do
no but people were saying I made a
reference to you be like a badass
a hard-ass boss yeah and first of all
even even say anything I said that about
her cuz I was trying to make her sound
cool ela let me just say you don't speak
for yourself is over at Teddy fresh she
is a she is a respected she there the
relationship because with her deploys is
amazing and she has an incredible team
of people with mutual respect for each
other
and what I was building up to be like
ela being a badass reprimanding someone
was just like a perfectly normal
conversation of healer just giving
someone feedback and I was trying to
make her sound cool and everything just
[ __ ] like that combined with with the
Ian part combined with the billionaire
conversation is like and I don't know
somehow I came off as like I'm I don't
know I mean there's it all came off so
wrong I guess I don't know am I possibly
can attest that we all really love
working here it's a lot of fun it's
great and you know you're very you're
always checking in with us you're very
present you're always making sure we're
all good
yeah no it's great I think people are
getting this perception that we all just
are like trapped here when we're not we
do actually like it yeah it's actually
the irony of that is is wild because I
mean the the whole perception of being
like a tyrannical boss it's really I
mean we have like the most autonomy I've
ever had in any job in my life here I
mean like you guys we we all make our
own hours you know I mean like you guys
give us a company card say just buy
whatever you want for the office like
it's always stocked up with like I trust
you guys totally yeah exactly and so
like it literally is like the most
laid-back work environment I've ever had
in my life so it couldn't be more the
opposite of that but again people don't
see that so you know when we're you're
doing the schtick that you're like the
Iron Fist boss or whatever that just
comes across is like that's what Ethan's
like see I felt like such a [ __ ]
idiot because like I gave off that
oppression and people believe that and
but I'm like I just I hate that because
I just I actually love you guys and
respect you all through you guys so much
that really you know everyone that we
work with even at Eddie fresh I it's
totally like did these are the people we
spend most of our time here and I tell
you friends like we talk all day we are
here the whole week between this office
that office and it's just everything
it's our life well when something comes
up I go immediately today she podcast
whatsapp group right yeah when I get
them five trillion crit and I just have
to say like you know I'm so grateful and
thankful to be working here I mean this
goes for Ian to I mean we both sent in
emails you know just immigrant fans of
the show and you know it's just been an
amazing opportunity and I love working
for you guys it's been amazing sex the
best isn't he's my golden boy Thank You
Zach but so just to just to recap none
of you are being held hostage there's no
gun off screen and all of you guys are
happy here right as happy as as we could
be yeah Wow no I know just again I do
want to say it's just like I mean I want
to Nestle anybody out but the people
making like a trillion [ __ ] threads
about this on the subreddit you know
defend Ian and kind of like turning him
into a martyr hmm it's a smart guy just
chill just chill like please like it's
it's not that big a deal I mean you know
you can you know you don't have to you
have to love everything on the show
absolutely and like your feedback is
fine but I don't know what other word to
call some of it not all of it but some
of it is quite frankly hysterical like
it's like people are being hysterical
about this and it you know just take a
step back it's a it's a podcast on
YouTube you know what I mean like it's
not that big a deal would you say it's
just a podcast okay
to quote ninja well you know but
ultimately I failed once again as a host
you know it's I feel I get frustrated
because it's like I feel like we claw
back we always have like these epic
downfalls and then I we claw back to
Iams
epic downfalls nobody who I claw back to
a good place
I'm feeling good I feel like the shows
on track and then it's like I just had a
nowhere again like everybody it's just
like chaos and and pandemonium mm-hmm
then it's like crawl back so I guess in
five months or something expect me to
what can I court early trauma it's not
good drama though it's awful drama that
makes my eye you know where places will
have like this many days since the last
injury that's a really good you should
put on the calendar like today Ethan
canceled so that we can do perhaps on it
yeah that's good yeah that's a great
idea but I I do want to apologize in if
I've ever put you in a weird spot or
forced you to speak out Dan I do want to
apologize for steamrolling you I guess
during that debate although I thought we
had a nice discussion I mean maybe I was
I don't know I just I just regret
allowing it to go on like you know I I I
personally love having spirit
discussions about politics but again
like I said earlier it's people don't
necessarily come here for that and so
you know a long extended diatribe about
that kind of stuff it's just it's not
the right it's not the content people
are looking to see and so we are not we
are out on politics we are in on corona
memes which have a lot of we are out on
bullying port Ian who is no longer in
turn he is a salaried employee he has
health insurance in a 401k and I have to
treat him like that right Ian that's
right right baby
and that's the other thing too people go
easy on Ethan because if he gets like
too upset about this and then just
cancels the podcast and we're all out of
the job so like help us out here
like give him a little encouragement for
some job security for
for your boy in Zack and myself well I
saw people saying they want you three to
go make a show and leave know about it
nobody wants to watch that show
I appreciate that that is that is
humbling thank you but it would be a
train wreck yeah absolutely
well now I don't want to see you even
like your you know for for for your many
numerous flaws oh no I mean the show
there would be no show without you you
you're you're the anchor you you have
the the extroverted you know frantic
energy that that makes it something yeah
and we're just bouncing off of you if we
didn't have you that this would not be
the same thing so now I really want this
for me I whenever I even just try to do
my segment on when I need to show a few
clips I go in like full panic mode I
don't ever want to do this again so I
don't know how you do this and I think
it's easy to take it for granted
and you also end up taking all the [ __ ]
usually because you're the one you're
the face of it but I mean we're all it's
a team effort I'm always on board with
what everything is doing we're always
planning everything and it's not just
eating you know but he ends up taking
the heat it feels so bad i but but it's
not your guy's fault it's always me that
does it like but at any rate thank you
guys I do now more than ever want to
watch you three do a show and me Neela
does switching and sound effects what if
you guys are better than me that would
be a disaster I'll have to pull the plug
no [ __ ] come in halfway through pull the
plug turn that off so I don't know is
there anything else to say about it no
probably not again do you have anything
else to add are you good is everyone
happy is everything been said mo good
okay yeah it's good I feel vindicated
I mean I was watching it back in yield
pulls out a Corona
we were all laughing I didn't know where
the dew pulls out of Corona and that was
a great bit that we had no idea but I
didn't see I mean I was sneaky sneaky
god bless wait a minute so now that we
have relitigated all this mm-hmm you
were being so evasive the other day how
the [ __ ] did you know that he was
feeling bad over the weekend
did you guys hear now I can't disclose
that I can't disclose it but I will say
that I am sorry for prying you know the
thing is like I got the Intel and for me
I just I love the dialogue with you guys
so I was trying to create a conversation
is all I didn't think of it as like
prying or anything but it turned it into
that and so once again I love iane I
love you I'm so thankful you know people
say in your superfan you reached out we
gave you the job and now I am the boss
from hell and I've ruined your life
you still are you still a super fan I do
like to show you yeah yeah he's not
super fan anymore but I don't blame me
once you get closer I don't think if you
if you worked for Kanye I don't think
he'd be a super fan well it's the
difference between like I see you every
day to be a fan right is odd like I I
know you that would be strange
okay I think we've said I mean I don't
want to I don't want to drag it out yeah
yeah we're dragon dragon but the thing
they actually upset me the most was
people [ __ ] on ela cuz I was like
dude she didn't do angry I said about
her not everyone's been like oh she's so
proud of being a shitty boss it's like
he was an awesome boss you think that
Teddy fresh would get where it was
without her working respectfully with
people I mean she works with a lot of
super talented people in a really
respectful way and there's a lot of
camaraderie and like really good synergy
in that office that's all I have to say
about that he is the greatest and how
dare anybody know I said I don't know
that's what I'd say thank you thank you
speaking of Corona I've got a bunch of
Corona memes here
you know we were we were debating if
Corona beer stock would go up or down as
a result just thinking that I had a
corona yesterday that's true you did
it's totally feels I liked it you feel
okay I felt refreshed I like that one w
epic if they were just putting
coronavirus and corona beer it's a club
well you know you got to put the
antidote like there instead of getting a
shot sorry good yeah what video positive
when they figure out how to prevent it
instead of giving it through a shot they
should put it in a corona oh that's
awesome that's the best marketing ever
if the beer company got ahold of the
antidote yeah just by Corona beer baby
that's a good PR move so we were saying
well maybe it will help with the brand
recognition maybe it will hurt well here
the the the facts are in owners of
Corona report 132 million pound loss for
Corona guys are getting hammered I was
shared that it would go up but here if
you want proof you thought it would go
up just from like the amount of like
name yeah but then you realize actually
help dumb people are and here's a
headline I saw 38% of Americans wouldn't
buy Corona beer under any circumstance
because of the cone coronavirus because
of corona virus or because because they
just don't like Corona
that's a funny thought they're like do
you like beer do like under no
circumstance right a lot of people hate
on Corona they go like this beer and
[ __ ] yeah it's kind of I like it I'd
like for that kind of be like I think I
like I like it I like it I like I like
her on a bad day I like it I like it I'm
trying to find I want to get to the
heart here they had here's a headline
that I saw trending this morning four
hours ago
Corona beard does not cause coronavirus
but a survey shows that the u.s.
purchase intent is down oh it's fine
even need to say that well it says here
they specifically say a widely cited
statistic that 38% of Americans won't
buy the Mexican lager because of the
coronavirus oh it's saying that's
misleading it's what am I doing here
is it because it is it what I said that
it might be don't like ya know ever
since this coronavirus thing people I've
been seeing a lot of people jokingly
saying like I would never buy corona boy
or Corona anyways cuz it sucks
yeah a lot of people like to hate it at
the same time here we were talking about
corona virus Corona ian's showing a
corona off screen I like Corona I'm
gonna say that for the record
but I guess there is such thing as bad
PR if that what if there was a virus
called like the Ethan virus yeah that
would probably ruin my life I mean
Corona is like the ultimate like good
happy time beer like if you sit on a
beach I agree I love it you put a lime
in there I see people go got to have
that Leno though I agree the lime X
video signal critical they are beer
doesn't need a lime think I don't angry
about it but the Mexicans man I've spent
a lot of time in Mexico my parents lived
there for a while those I mean they just
they they drink Corona there it's not
like marketing like they love Corona I
guess like Americans of Budweiser and
that's what I'm like give me the choice
between those two I'll take the Corona
every time well there you go so
apparently it is hurting the brand and
speaking of Corona this is the best
thing I've ever seen this was on Fox
News so you know how I was telling you
guys that there was people who got a
straw it's for the best thing to you
cannot believe this video you're gonna
freak they brought a bunch of Americans
over from from like China or from the
cruise ship I don't know I don't know
from where they came but they returned
home after going through a corona virus
quarantine for two weeks okay now enjoy
this guy was
daughter it's like a communist he goes
forward hopefully doctors and scientists
will get it better better handle on the
whole situation fortunately from what I
understand you know it isn't ages but
the death rate is is pretty low I
understand fear yeah well we can see you
still have a coughing what did the
doctors say about your own condition
moving forward as we wrap this up they
share the water with my daughter I think
you put twice negative both times the
cough probably just some assuming they
have like some kind of slant towards
like cuz trumps like we got it under
control it's all good and in the
beginning he's like wow the mortality
late rates pretty low so not a big deal
is this the best thing you've ever seen
it's like comedy sketch yeah
takes the water from his daughter drinks
and then gives it back to her he's
coughing awesome does coughing is does
nerves cause coughing I mean you're the
coffee expert I think I think Corona
causes coughing it's awesome moving
forward as we wrap this or so far
let me get some of that yeah I'm fine I
got tested twice negative both times is
the best cough probably just like
getting out of here not there no just
get another kid out to them oh this is
the best it's so good so yeah I think I
personally think we're I think it's out
I think we're [ __ ] I think we're gonna
have a pandemic on our hands and we are
we're just gonna have to deal with it
write it out scary Mike Pence was named
head of coronavirus prevention which is
excellent considering that he's best
quipped to deal with it right now he is
a praying or the God to take care of it
and that's about as good as anybody can
do so I'm so I'm feeling much better
since uh I knew that Mike Pence was
praying for good hands um stockmarket
man it's taking a big one Dan you got
out you got out at a good time yeah me
and me and a lot of other people
apparently cuz that's part of why it's
crashing is everybody's panicking but uh
oh wow bounce back bounce back up today
it's only down eight point eight percent
today oh that's not too bad it's
bouncing around a lot like it was down
yeah it's just very volatile uh yeah no
I mean I was seeing a lot of news over
the weekend so I went ahead and I pulled
out completely and just in the nick of
time
congratulations I don't have to but I
feel I mean God it's just it's such a it
seems like such a gamble to put your
money in there and you just like so
emotional from day-to-day ups and downs
you know it's like hello and I think
that keys to not look at it daily right
yeah I generally
although you know in circumstances like
this where
see the writing on the wall that you
know something big was probably coming
you know I wasn't about to just write
this out but but yeah I'll keep an eye
on it and when things settle down if
they settle down like that again yeah
exactly
dance a day trader man he's a slick
trader yeah it's exaggeration mm-hmm
quite a day trader you thinking I'm not
I'm not on a daily basis buying and
selling
you made a killing on beyond me right I
did pretty good with beyond me honestly
so that's that exact means you guys
trade it all or is this a little bit oh
yeah I have some penny stocks I own and
I have some Amgen Apple stuff like that
do you don't do check it like you've
messed with it or you just sit on it I
just let it ride yeah let it ride baby
I don't really touch any of that stuff
yeah it's tough I'm pretty smooth brain
smooth brain oh is that like yeah I'm
operating at sea level
Oh a smooth brain is like what they is
like an army thing oh really
am I right or am I the the it's because
the wrinkles in your gray matter or
theoretically Oh where'd your
intelligence comes from so beings oh
yeah that's a great insult yeah I
probably look so out of touch because
I've heard that before
it was brain you thought it was a
compliment
no I know it I know it yeah is it like
numb school would it be the same thing
numb school that's a smooth brain so
okay that's that now let's move on to
what really matters here I felt we
talked about the role patrol let me show
you the original video we were all
enjoying it for this so if somebody
emailed me and said yo this guy's got a
YouTube channel check him out and I
started looking at his content and I
could not believe what I was seeing
some of these videos are so amazing I
can't believe they don't have 20 million
views in here I am watching them with
like 4000 views
mind blown I'm in the office Heelys
they're with me I'm working and I'm
dying and I refuse to show her because I
wanted to show it to her on the show
yeah
so here I mean for those who didn't see
here's the original video roll patrol we
call them
dude sniffs a roll puts it back in at
the grocery store
sniffs that wrong I've seen it you
specially use the wax paper when you
touch the rolls
I'm roll Patrol dude seriously need the
wax paper and you're sniffing them and
then you're touching them and you're
putting them back
[Music]
they smell like [ __ ]
just do me a favor just pick up the ones
you touched and buy them because I don't
want I don't want to I don't know where
your dick beaters been yeah yeah I mean
[Music]
let's pick them the [ __ ] off and put
them in your bag or I'm gonna even you
up
I'm Tony right now I'm gonna even you to
[ __ ] off I'm not kidding yeah
disgusting I know it's like the greatest
video everything I thought it was a
one-off so I thought this was a one-off
but it turns out this guy's a vigilante
all over the great city of Philadelphia
where else could somebody like this be
from his YouTube channel is called the
Philly offensive so here we go I am
veiled to you today
he doesn't need milk all right enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] dude who just [ __ ] saved your
life no I was like what he doesn't need
milk good
he doesn't need milk I mean I mean
unpack that this video has 40,000 views
wow that was like a movie yeah I hate to
be this guy are we a hundred percent
sure these are real cuz that was like so
I think it's really makes me skeptical
those kids that they actually hand it to
people for this situation yeah yeah I
was fully with it until he got up and
kicked the dude in pause this is just so
great I mean I I I cannot believe that
the kid know how amazing it just works
like it brings her back and yeah because
I saw a 60 Minutes on it and um right I
saw that too
yeah it's amazing you put it in the nose
and it Sobers them immediately yeah it's
awesome looking you know for like a bad
like a bad weed hi you know sometimes I
smoke too much weed and you're like I'm
so over this just sniff some [ __ ] that'd
be so awesome don't know better do you
remember the name yep amazing it's like
it's like magic you're literally dying
and brings you back
cause this guy's dick chaney if you can
they're in the right time but was the
milk like putting milk in it was kicking
him after he brought him back kayo ding
and they're pouring milk in his mouth
that's amazing that's a masterpiece yeah
yeah I was blown away absolutely blown
away the Philly offensive but hold on
that's just one video the next one
welcome to Philly let's see what's up
this guy he just keeps throwing trash
out as how does car window but he
doesn't even care
he doesn't even [ __ ] care just guys
like the real Batman yeah that's what he
said in the comment of the role the
choice that I'm half man who does that
what's this can go buddy I noticed you
get weight from Florida and there's the
place yeah Tampa yeah
what are you [ __ ] lost why are you
throwing your weight on your trash all
over the ground on sale Street there's
trash can right there
what the hell does that mean yeah you
like hospital food do you like hospital
food good look I don't think you're
trash to put in the trash can that's all
you're gonna be [ __ ] eat I can't
believe he actually gets this table to
comply comply isn't any forces they
always look like they're gonna fight it
but they don't he must be a huge scary
guy wow this videos and this forty five
thousand yeah these are his most viewed
videos because I just sort of by popular
thoughts thoughts and prayers like I
hope I hope to god it's not fake that's
all I gotta say yeah like it's usually
my fake router is pretty accurate and I
don't think these are hey that's true
you are really good at and I mean like
the video with the narcan I mean those
two put it like I mean those look like
real junkies yeah you know I mean like
it didn't seem like a sketch but if it
is the acting is so good it's like when
I was funny either way absolutely if I
watch Jerry Springer I know people
always say it's fake and I know it is
fake but the thing that always trip me
out about Jerry Springer is like how
these people are really good actors then
and I've never seen them anywhere else
cuz they sell it yeah well yeah on
things like Jerry Springer I mean it's
fake to the extent that it's like it's a
set up scenario but I think the people
are real you know what I mean like
they're not actors in the sense like
they're they're trained actors they're
like they're yelling they're real where
does yeah yeah and then they're like
told like get into a fight you know like
play it up kind of thing so here's
another line I mean I've got several
more this one I couldn't believe you
know I mean this one's called this one's
called steak is for taxpayers
and this is one of them situations yeah
dude yeah yeah I noticed you bought your
groceries with a with a welfare car but
then you use cash to buy lottery tickets
what I noticed you you [ __ ] you use
the access card to buy your groceries
and then you bought scratch offices with
cash you think it's right whoa so what
[Music]
why why are you using a welfare car to
buy food but then you're buying
scratch-off lottery tickets with cash it
is my [ __ ] business I pay taxes my
business it is it is my business because
I work for a living and I pay taxes Wow
pregnant smoking and pajama pants you
like a [ __ ] triple [ __ ] up steak is
for [ __ ] taxpayers Wow
up and I was with it until they took
their stuff come on you can't dude steak
is for taxpayers dance the students the
biggest balls I mean what is going on he
must be ten feet tall
what is gonna win in Philadelphia like
it's a beautiful dude it's beautiful
Philadelphia you've got the richest
characters in the world I mean that guy
was like dozing off in the background
right Linnea on dakar we must live in a
rough like Nick I don't think all
affiliate but yeah Billy's got a
reputation it's kind of a rough town
yeah it's a rough town I know that about
it you get characters you know eight
come on you've actually been there and
it looks pretty nice well we were i
agree like the center yeah look you know
if there's a city of people walk around
eating Philly cheesesteaks you know it's
a rough city and then finally this one
caught he goes and saves a dog I'm on
Livingston Street I got a call
friends called me and said that the
whoever owns this [ __ ] dog leaves it
out all the time and I just knocked for
like 10 minutes
no answer so wherever it is it's
probably [ __ ] drunk and this dog was
left out and during the storm for hours
and I got three people from a rescue I'm
afraid to do alright okay alright if you
just want to play you just want to play
and is this your dog
why is the dog left now 24 hours a day
when in this weather they're BOTS to
sleep on what are you doing on my
property the door gets cold the dog gets
why I got three I'm just letting you
know so I got three people coming here
and they're taking this [ __ ] dog my
[ __ ] dog yeah they are no not why
don't you there's nothing out here to
[ __ ] protect it don't you know don't
you know that dogs you call Bay a cold
it's a dog dude it's a dog they get
caught can I tell you this one fella
spoke it was cool I got a call that it
was out here in the storm it wasn't out
here in the storm no so several people
lied to me
yeah alright well I just want you to
know three I got three friends coming
right now they're taking that [ __ ]
dog yeah they are big and they're taking
that [ __ ] E they're taking that
[ __ ] dog you piece of [ __ ] so fight
no I just petted her she ain't doing
[ __ ] ya know if you're too [ __ ]
stupid to realize that the dog gets cold
and your to stop [ __ ] stupid to
realize you should know the dog right
I'll be back I'll be back
come on
so ela you said you think this one's
fake big guy felt like it was that thing
dog yeah I could see that a little bit I
think real patrols fake
oh yeah it's calling it anyone else have
an put I want to believe
well I talked briefly with the roll
patrol an email they are all staged he's
a comedian based in Philly what and he's
been staged he does these are comedy
sketches oh my he's got see the guy's a
genius
how did it do the one with the I think I
don't know I must he must have recruited
a real pie maybe it gets people yeah on
it but like it's so perfectly
orchestrated yeah yeah there's matches
little things like no one says why are
you filming me for example I feel like
that's a big thing yeah that was I had
that thought as well
they're amazing I'm so impressed with
this guy he's such a legend to Philly
offensive only four thousand subscribers
Wow a suti uploaded three days ago one
day ago so I joke around a lot that's
our bad as him you know making videos
and having fun but I want to get serious
for a moment I love his voice yeah a lot
of people don't know this but I was uh I
was adopted and
[Music]
I finally tracked down my biological
mother she's actually sitting on the
steps next to me I've been here about
for a half hour I'm super nervous I had
to go through ancestry.com spend five I
mean eight thousand dollars took about
15 years to find her and here we go like
this what an unsung genius a palm do
yeah hi Karen
are you Karen are you Karen my name is
Tim I'm your son
[Applause]
yeah she's wearing a forehead I track
you down through ancestry.com
no it's I'm serious
it took me 15 years to find you how do
you want well looking open like your
father
yeah that looks like a dick are you
serious
I came here become here for you no Tim
Tim can I can I get a hug at least he's
still up to his high jinks one it
reminds me of like reno911.com yeah
that's a good comparison so how did you
find out you just asked him yeah why I
was like dude you're awesome we want we
want to call in and hear from you and
he's like hey just so you know he was
very upfront and he's like just so you
know I'm a comedian in Philly these are
all staged there you go that's amazing
he told me right up front those videos
masterpieces yeah that milk one
masterpiece yeah that one is like a
short film yeah I mean oh my god
I love the milk that you doesn't need
milk dude like he thought of that detail
of a bomb pouring milk in his mouth
that's epic so awesome also you know
what throws it off what what junkie has
milk on him when I roll with milk mm-hmm
I'm a little I mean it's still funny
but I am disappointed that roll Patrol
isn't real just because I all right I
really I want to do well there's a dirt
just no take comfort in knowing that
there is a real roll patrol out there
he's just not filming
you know I mean he's out there living
the life he doesn't need the accolades
he doesn't need that clays he's just
there to patrol the rolls I'm another
colliding world's big Edie was
who puts mayonnaise in his hair from TLC
we enjoyed his video I'm not going to
show it because they claim us everytime
TLC is a relentless man but we have made
contact here I'll show picture of Big Ed
we talk about them so much I mean can we
get a little I mean they should be
paying me at this one not taking my
revenue this is big Edie look at the
film oh my god
props to whoever is doing took me a
minute to understand what what a wise
he's guess her pros man look at that
that's big ad what the male in the hair
and we got ahold of him
Zach did some incredible legwork and
forgot her got in touch with big Edie
and we're working on getting him on the
show because what I would like to do
should I say it I mean I'll say I have a
great idea let's keep it a surprise
keep it close to the chest I think so
but here I am very excited that he's
coming on here um this is from his
Twitter oh he's got a dog named Teddy
and a back now with the bubble what
though with an observatory yeah yeah
that's real that's him this is him on a
moped and his dog Teddy look at this he
drives a Vespa with his dog and a glass
war on his back this guy his dogs
astronaut awesome shredder would never
sit still can you imagine
no but Alfredo would yeah Alfredo would
he's on Twitter even he's a twitch
streamer
curious vacuuming glitter off cookies I
just dumped I realize oh he's so cute so
I kind of yeah hold on a second hold on
there's someone filming
[Music]
too much sprinkles and then he vacuumed
it off
what how do I get the sprinkles off yeah
again yeah making moves the goat yeah
big add the goat here he is showing
proper sword stance have a view that's a
deep cut throw eight and we watched it a
couple of times that the beat Steve cut
I love how that overlay covers his head
but you know this is you needed to use
baby and by that while she straps to the
samurai sword not cheeto because that's
due to strapping a sword to his way a
straight up samurai sword
I wonder thing will cruise around Japan
the man and then there's a one other one
a look at young bit bigger I was so
impressed what a honky is look at Ed
good-looking guy damn handsome devil
he's still handsome he's got beautiful
moisturised hair where's the picture of
him doing the tutu I dropped it in here
oh here it is I got it good and then
finally just to set the stage for big
Ed's appearance here on the podcast
[Laughter]
he's wearing a ballerina tutu he's all
tatted okay folks
I missed my sales goal okay I did a
million 50,000 and I said I would do 1.5
million stickers what happens so yay
dude yeah I was so impressed by that
jump that jump is perfectly I got a
positive anytime before look at that wow
I don't think I could do that no it's
pretty good what is he selling that he's
his sales I was 1.5 million dollars
that's a lot I'm very intrigued by that
as well it looks like he's in a trailer
park community maybe sells RVs or
something maybe that would maybe add up
to so he did a million in sales that's
pretty good yeah I mean how much
commission you make on that I don't know
I don't know how much RV people make but
uh I'm car car salesman make really good
Commission so he did this so perfect I
can't believe that that's incredible
with the two - I mean the air was
perfect the form was perfect flawless
big add the goat give that guy a samurai
sword he'll lead a country let's be good
so we're excited to have made contact
with big Edie of TLC the man he's in the
hair guy Zach tell me I mean you're the
one that got a hold of him tell me about
the conversation well I guess I got to
give credit to Ian because he did find
the phone number
oh that was yeah Wow thank you thank you
same work but Zach really brought it
home really yeah so I called him and it
went straight to voicemail
this was a few days ago and then moving
forward I called him and I think it was
three days ago something like that
and he picked up the phone and he was
like just like not super friendly and
not you know he wasn't willing to
communicate what did he say he's I'll
talk to my people and he gave me an
email address talk to my people but he's
big ed big he's got people he's got
people for that so I shot them in email
and then the day after that I get a call
at 8 o'clock in the morning and it's big
at himself and Wow super like apologetic
yeah he's all like yeah you know I know
h3h3 and like you know I saw the clips
and like it's awesome and even retweeted
the clip from the podcast Oh so
hopefully he didn't see me being mean
day in don't want to come on anymore but
like yeah we're we're getting it all set
up wow that's so cool yeah it's crazy
like the worlds are colliding we got the
Philly offensive we got Big Ed we've got
I wasn't there another one yes Casey who
lost oh my God all the way Casey from
TLC the guy who was bathing in the
trough with dishsoap and Carl's jr.
cobbb mm-hmm then he lost a bunch away
actually do I have that video so we're
not gonna watch that video let's watch
it I guess this is like the whole this
is everything's coming together here
episode Oh
memes I lined oh maybe we'll watch it
next week yeah but we got ahold of him
he lost a bunch of weight he saw us cuz
yes we could like use a van yeah I'm a
fan of his because he's lost a ton of
weight he's looking really good I'm so
happy for him I have weight problems I
struggle with my weight it's so hard for
me to lose weight but someone that size
to Glu's as much weight as he has is
amazing love it
love to see it he's gonna call him we're
gonna find out I'm so curious about
people who have worked with TLC me too
and I want to know it sounds almost like
he regrets doing the show I don't know
if it motivated him what was it like
we're going to producers like how they
set up that shot right in his crotch
like what is it like working with those
midnight those people are just evil
geniuses right yeah so I have a lot to
ask
reality show producers are there there
there's a certain breed I mean dude they
set up the camera right here it was
crazy that shot how do you even like
have the the balls to do that they've
got it you know what I mean think
they've got it all they've got the balls
so that's exciting let's see they did
this was a highly asked or this question
on Twitter got a lot of traction he said
hey Ethan why the sensitive is a drawing
do you see that
yes hey Ethan and Eli would like to know
if there's three windows for Zach dan
and Ian - looking through I've been
wondering this and this my wife is a lie
even did a sketch so yeah I love this
it's so funny to me basically this is
what we wish we had
but then basically did his magic here
and what we have is a laptop where he
has the windows drawn we have a laptop
and it's a split screen of the cameras
so we can see there the dense camera
right now for example it's a preview
monitor it's a preview monitor yeah and
so we see Ian's life switching and we
see we have to show it we have to show
it can we show it Dan yeah give me a sec
okay go ahead so yeah let's just go
handheld on this paper so I don't think
anyone expected there's a wall here it's
just a wall but then the real crazy one
is can you see how you guys see from
back there right can you just show your
webcam flip your webcam around yeah good
hey and so here's the big reveal the
truth is there are no windows yeah
there's a giant TV screen right in front
of them and here's Zach and Ian and Dan
is obviously the point of view and they
look at this television and they see
everything that's happening through
there because there is actually a room
between us which is something you
wouldn't expect right we had to make it
work with this office well it's not
really like an office for dance the Dan
is the we call him de Medicis we call
them the wizard and the magician for a
reason also his backpack is like the
magic bus there's always like whatever
you're gonna need it hasn't really
there's anything I give tweezers yeah I
think I have some pair literally dan do
you have a spermicidal Lube yeah I think
I got that just whatever you need you
know
but but just to put in perspective I'm
staring at the guys the three guys
there's Ian there's Ian is that I'm
sorry yeah
Ian Zak is right behind here and Dan is
right here but there is a room between
our room between us yeah it's all movie
magic in here Dan it's all movie magic
so maybe one day we could get to that
but I think it's pretty cool what we've
configured because you don't need a
window right you guys do you guys need a
window you feel like are you happy with
the setup
I personally I'm very happy with the
setup long term I would love to do that
yeah yeah I mean we I don't know if
we'll ever move into a new studio it's
not really something we can do in the
space but if we ever moved I would
definitely set it up in such a way that
we had an actual window like that just
put a giant glass window so yeah that'd
be cool I mean that's that's very
typical like on most radio shows and
everything the producers are looking
through glass like that but um but this
isn't bad you know this this works yeah
it's better than when we first were
doing we didn't have anything like this
yeah it was ghetto man there was a desk
right outside the door in the corner
that weren't you sitting at that at one
point Dan so you could see in at me yeah
exactly yeah that was weird but we
prefer to close the door so basically we
wouldn't see each other unless we left
it open because the reality is this
whole show like when you guys were first
starting it you didn't know how long
you'd do it yeah we were it so it's been
built up over time you know if if we
were coming into it and just trying to
do it at the level that we do now from
funding right it would be done in a
different way but this has kind of been
like a it's it's evolved over time I
love it I love where it's at it's a
shame that it's got that come to an end
because
and frankly I blame you in for for
provoking me to bully us right as we
come to the close here Trisha Paytas I'm
so excited that's gonna be by the way I
have to say podcasting Russians calm get
your applications in because we're
coming to a close here right the
deadline what is uh-oh we actually know
we have more time we had said March 7th
which is not this Sunday but the
following Sunday March 7th okay so it's
like a week you have one week we have
one more than the following we wanted to
have her on that Friday cuz that would
be before that week is over you know it
would not you know that's coming Friday
it would be than their next week yeah
exactly
so she's gonna come another 13th we're
going to review the applications that
we've received which according to these
guys are incredible I've I knew it would
be pretty good you people that have
submitted your really you're bringing it
it's we've got so exciting there's and
what let me just say that since the
competition is highs if you want to win
this girl's heart you better come hard
with your video you have one week left
you guys and she said that she is
intending to marry this is what I wanted
to say she tweeted please only apply to
ht3 if you tend to marry me in the
following 30 days okay so I mean hello
only 30 days that's a third of what
90-day fiance gives you is there gonna
be a prenup because that could be a huge
landfall that's insane right no prenup
now we're cooking hmm so there you go we
have that look sounds like it's
negotiable the 30 days the brain up is
negotiable yeah we learned that from
watching 90 day the newest episode
there's this guy or the newest season
there's this guy who's like 45 and he
scoops up some like 18 year old model
from Brazil she's 20 about 20 excuse me
she's so much more mature than I give
her credit for and then the guy has some
money actually for the first time in 90
day fiancé history yeah he doesn't live
in a one-room
apartment the and FISA dude that was a
drug dealer I mean it was yeah no that
guy was broke it was broke that was the
whole friction was that a problem they
portray themselves as rich and they're
like yeah come here I'm gonna spend
money on you that guy was in like a
one-room apartment and they all are they
always do that and so this guy actually
has money although I have to get this
guy's money and then so he's gonna marry
her and he wants her to sign a prenup
which makes sense to me but I don't know
if to hurt doesn't make sense because
she says that dude this whole thing was
crazy she was I'm an independent woman I
don't need no man I need to figure out
my own life and all this and yada yada
yada but at the same time she says she's
not going through with it if she doesn't
get the prenup or removed it was a
beautiful thing though it was great to
follow because I went to a lawyer and
the lawyer was like railing on him like
dude you can't just and the lawyer was
right she's like you can't just throw
her out on the street if it doesn't work
out mm-hmm so they got rid of prenup no
prenup no prenup and then did she take I
stalked them a little bit on Instagram
they're still together
I don't know how long's it's been but
does he's always pretty boring so yeah
we balanced on that unfortunately but
that's why I'm excited for big Edie
bigad is the the promise of a great new
season of 90 day fiancé man easy hair
baby I want to see if he's with that
girl well I think it all happens live so
he's in the process of waiting for the
90 day now oh my god Oh crazy
our worlds are really colliding and
finally ela does this make you hungry
Burger King's new burger
he's trying to sell us a burger I think
was this a Super Bowl ad uh no it came
out a little bit after the Super Bowl
right it came out like a week ago oh
yeah so they are showing off their
showing a time-lapse of the burger
molding and rowdy I'm supposing an
effort to make you appreciate that their
food is not have preservatives in it but
I don't want to eat this hamburger ever
that's disgusting
like right I mean this is putrid no this
is absolutely awful
I don't know what the [ __ ] they were
they don't even the beauty of no
artificial preservatives you've just
permanently like associated rotten meat
with Burger King to my mind they should
have at least showed the jute like it
looks good here they should have at
least showed it like hey this is what it
actually looks like I mean who's gonna
want to eat this to close up on the mold
growing it's just like no one wants to
see that let's see what the Komets are
some of us we either be fired or
promoted I'm not eating that [ __ ] ever I
don't I'm never going to Burger King and
for those reasons I'm out that's it we
have said it all we have we've said it
all have we not we've said it all I
think but also but yet so that's that's
the podcast I hope you all enjoyed it
somehow I feel like people are gonna be
even more angry at me than before do you
feel work in progress we're trying stuff
I mean we're always like trying to keep
evolving this show and not do the same
thing and so a lot of this stuff or like
attempts and something mmm and like you
know the whole interaction and
relationship with Ian on camera it's
just kind of like an attempt at being
funny really and it just didn't really
work definitely did not work
but I do want to take the criticism and
learn from it I don't want people to
think that we're not and I just have to
stop doing this shtick where I'm like
angry like I go - yeah because for some
reason that seems like the funny thing
to do but it's not yeah it's not I guess
and because it's really not like that
our relationship is not like that well
that would be insane of course yeah yeah
I mean that kind of like humor works on
a TV show but I think you know on the
podcast people like the podcast because
they feel like it's a group of people
just hanging out casually or whatever
and so when it like Ana day I'm like
kind of like wrestler fake reality comes
down to it not everybody gets it so it's
just a weird mix cuz it is real and we
aren't having real conversations you
know so well it was bad who's bad stupid
but I do honestly truly think that I
know we've done like 180 episodes almost
maybe this is 180 but to me in my mind
this is still like the beginning of the
podcast for me we're still figuring it
out
yeah I'm still feeling oh I want to do a
thousand episodes so we're about a fifth
bill away there I want to do more than a
thousand Dan I want to keep you guys
locked up forever do you guys have any
final words anybody before we wrap this
up
yeah to the people who's reddit threads
are deleted and you got pissed off deal
with it I'm sorry your karma got lost
but there's people freaking out about
that and I don't care I'll delete it
again thank you Dan I appreciate that
uh I'll just say I mean in these four
walls it's it's all love and it always
has been so that's that's the reality of
the situation so I love you too
you didn't say you love me but I love
you too it's all and Zach my golden boy
boy where would I be without you
again thank you guys for this
opportunity and I mean now people are
just gonna make make me a theme like I'm
making yourself very great in the
Bahamas yeah major key I mean it's just
amazing I love working here thank you
thank you I love having you dropped out
of [ __ ] call it you should come work
here yeah oh that's see that doesn't
sound good for me it's cool I said look
I don't want you to drop out of school
Zac you know but if you're gonna do it
you've always got a full-time job here
with us because he was just doing freely
I left college to Jake good for me such
a hypocrite anything whatever man you go
to school get a job all you get offer
for full-time job I mean if I if I got a
full-time job I probably would drop out
because college was you end up spending
all this money and the B pray to God you
could find a job afterward right yeah
I'm gonna take it when the opportunity
comes it's [ __ ] you guys will always
have a job here thank you
unless you cross me all right so that's
the weekend hell yeah and I do apologize
to the audience because I'm I don't want
anyone to come out feeling I mean I want
everyone it should be coming here having
fun this is a toxic work environment
yeah I guess people were concerned for
us and okay good but I'm but people were
very upset so I'm sorry about that and
apologies to ends mom as well yeah oh
wow
I never meant to hurt you I never meant
to make you cry well that's up what what
song is that
I'm just the jealous guy Oh see that's
actually wasn't what I was singing but
it's not it's go ahead and sing it I
don't remember the rest sorry mom
that's not ever meant to hurt that's
what I see that's how we just got
claimed I never made to make you cry cuz
tonight I'm sniffing you what is he
saying I'm cleaning out my clothes out
and out my closet I thought you were
singing jealous guy by John it did some
more like right yeah that was a way to
remix addition mom are you guys good
singers most are kids that zach has a
beautiful voice thank you I knew that
about him already
thank you Ian do you sing no no no no no
no no no you know what sucks is I have a
terrible singing voice and both of my
parents especially my mom is like a
fantastic singer like naturally like
really really gifted you got yeah yeah
like what the [ __ ] where those jeans
being a good singers the coolest thing I
know always and I'm so bad it's like I
don't know if it's like if you either
can sing or you can't but when you can't
boy boy boy boy no no but that's like
you don't understand the effort it took
like I'm not it's not effortless yes
some people are just gifted many people
okay I can't do anything like not even
close to where you can do I did like 30
takes okay and then they cut together
the pieces they wasn't even one day of
takes that I could do okay
I'm not a good singer don't stroke me I
like it okay I'll take it I think you
need to do another album a new song I
like it
I do want to we have to work with my
friend Isaac who's he's a family man
that'd be really cool I'd like to hear
that you should get on it hmm
get some we should get some like we
should do like the acoustic cuz we've
kind of lucked into full music and then
get Zach shredding it or just like a
solo a guitar solo song he's sick it'd
be cool alright well let's have a let's
have a good weekend everybody
yeah all right everybody
all right thank you guys for the nice
words by the way I appreciate you guys
come into my support I appreciate it
and I do genuinely love you mean you
guys like my family I mean I it's
embarrassing but I do love you guys
sweetly and genuinely I would be
devastated if you ever left me seriously
heartbroken you always got a job at
Teddy fresh if this doesn't work on you
gonna I'm gonna fire them and you're
gonna hire them it's getting it's
getting sad alright alright guys thank
you so much have a blessed weekend well
we have a guest uh next right Andrew
sands and Santino Santino I believe I
just I get confused cuz his name is like
cheeto run Andrew Santino hilarious
comedian he rolls with Bobby Lee and
Chris D'Elia and Theo von he's part of
that Comedy Store gang of comedians
super funny guy he's actually in this
season of curb which is crazy it's so
cool I booked him and then that night
saw the episode with him in it I didn't
know he was on there and was like what
the [ __ ] I know he was in the presence
of Larry David awesome
he has good luck for eternity shake his
hand yeah just push hands shake Larry's
now let me shake you and then the
episode after that we have PewDiePie
coming right PewDiePie is scheduled for
well PewDiePie was originally scheduled
for Tuesday but he had to reschedule to
Friday right he just let us know
so PewDiePie will be on Friday thank you
for reminding me and look forward to
speaking with him so much stuff to talk
about
can't wait yeah can't wait alright
that's about it guys so thank you very
much have a great weekend and stay
blessed appreciate you all very much in
see you next up bye
[Music]